I thought I'd read you a little of the
winds of winter just a little I don't
have time to do a whole chapter here but
I'll read you the beginning of a chapter
that's true I just heard somebody say I
want to hear it but I don't want to hear
it now if you haven't read if you
haven't read all the books off to and
including A Dance with Dragons you might
want to leave because uh this takes up
right right where to dance with dragons
leaves off it takes it off like like
five minutes after the end of a dance
with Dragons so brace yourself your
you'll be right in the middle of it here
Victorian the noble lady was a tub of a
ship as fat and wallowing as the noble
ladies of the green lands her holds were
huge and Victorian pack them with armed
men with her would sail the other lesser
prizes that the iron fleet had taken on
his long voyage to slavers Bay a l'bri
assortment of cogs great cogs Care Act's
and trading galleys salted here and
there with fishing boats it was a fleet
both fat and feeble promising much in a
way of wool and wines and other trade
goods and little in the way of danger
the carrion gave the command of it to
wolf one year the slavers made shiver
when they spy your sails rising from the
sea told him but once they see you plain
they will laugh at their fears traitors
and fishers that's all you are any man
can see that let them get close as they
like but keep your men hidden below
ducks until you're ready then close and
board them free the slaves and feed the
slavers to the sea but take the ships we
will have need of every Hall to carry us
back home home wolf grinned a man will
like the sound of that Lord captain the
ships first then we break these yunkish
men I the iron victory was lashed
alongside the noble lady the two
ships bound tight with chains and
grappling hooks a ladder stretched
between them the great cog was much
larger than the warship and sat higher
in the water all along the gun walls the
faces of the Ironborn peered down
watching as Victorian clapped wolf one
air on the shoulder and sent him
clambering up the ladder the sea was
smooth and still the sky bright with
stars Woolf ordered the ladder drawn up
the chains cast off the warship in the
cod parted ways in the distance the rest
of Victorians famed fleet was raising
sail a ragged cheer went up from the
crew of the iron victory and was
answered in kind by the men of the noble
lady Victarion had given wolf his best
fighters he envied them they would be
the first to strike a blow the first to
see that look of fear in the foeman's
eyes as he stood at the prow of the iron
victory watching one ears merchant ships
vanish one by one and to the west the
faces of the first foe he'd ever slain
came back to Victorian Greyjoy he
thought of his first ship of his first
woman a restlessness was in him a hunger
for the dawn and the things this day
would bring death or glory I will drink
my fill of both today the sea stone
chair should have been his when Balon
died but his brother you're on it stolen
it from him just as he had stolen his
wife many years before he stole her and
he soiled her but he left it for me to
slay her all that was done and gone now
though Victarion would have his due at
last I have the horn and soon I will
have the woman a woman lovelier than the
wife he made me kill captain the voice
belonged to long water pike the oarsmen
await your pleasure three of them and
strong ones send her to my cabin
I want the priest as well the oarsmen
were all big one was a boy one a brute
one of bastards bastard the boy had been
rowing for less than a year the brute
for 20 they had names what Victorian did
not know them one had come from
lamentation one from Sparrowhawk one
from spider kiss he could not be
expected to know the names of every
throw
who had ever pulled an oar in the iron
fleet show them the horn he commanded
when the three had been ushered into his
cabin mokoro brought it forth and the
dusky woman lifted up a lantern to give
them all look in the shifting Lantern
light the hell horn seemed to rise and
turn into priests hands like a serpent
fighting to escape mokoro was a man of
monstrous size big belly broad
shouldered towering but even in his
grasp the horn looked huge
my brother found this thing on valaria
Victarion silver Scrolls
think of big the dragon must have been
to bear two of these upon his head
bigger than veigar or more oxys bigger
than balerion the black dread he took
the horn from mokoro and ran his palm
along his curves at the Kings mouton old
wick one of Euron's mutes blew upon this
horn some of you will remember there was
not a sound that any man who heard it
will ever forget they say died the boy
said him who blew the horn I the horn
was smoking after the mute had blisters
on his lips and the bird inked across
his chest was bleeding he died the next
day when they cut him open his lungs
were black the horn is cursed said the
bastards bastard a dragon's horn from
Valerius at Victorian high it's cursed I
never said it wasn't he brushed his hand
across one of the red gold bands and the
ancient glyph seemed to sing beneath his
fingertips for half a heartbeat he
wanted nothing so much as to sound the
horn himself urine was a fool to give me
this it is a precious thing and powerful
with this I'll win the sea stone chair
and then the iron throne with this I'll
win the world clag Orrin blew the horn
thrice and died for it he was the big as
any of you and strong as me so strong
that he could twist a man's head right
off his shoulders with only his bare
hands and yet to horn killed him it will
kill us too then said the boy Victarion
did not all forgive a Thrall for talking
out of turn but the boy was young no
more than 20 and soon to die besides he
let it pass
the mute sounded the horn three times
you three will sound that only once
might be you'll die might be you won't
omen die the iron fleet of sailing into
battle many on this very ship will be
dead before the Sun Goes Down stabbed or
slashed gutted drowned burned alive only
two gods know which of us will still be
here come tomorrow sound the horn and
live and I'll make freemen of you one or
two or all three
I'll give you wives a bit of land a ship
to sail thralls of your own men will
know your names even you Lord captain as
to bastards bastard
aye I'll do it then and me said the boy
to brood crossed his arms and nodded if
it made the three feel braver to believe
they had a choice let them cling to that
Victarion kid little what they believed
they were only thralls you will sail
with me on iron victory he told them but
you will not join the battle boy you're
the youngest you'll sound the horn first
when the time comes you will blow it
long and loud they say are strong blow
the horn until you're too weak to stand
until the last bit of breath has been
squeezed from you to your lungs are
burning but the freedmen hear you in
marine the slavers in eunuch I the
ghosts in Astapor
let the monkey [ __ ] themselves at the
sound when it rolls across the Isle of
cedars then passed a horn along to the
next man do you hear me do you know what
to do the boy and the bastard bastards
tug their forelocks the brute might have
done the same but he was bald you may
touch the horn then go they left him one
by one the three thralls and then mokoro
victorian would not let him take the
hill horn I will keep it here with me
until it's needed as you command
would you have me bleed you victory and
see is the dusky woman by the wrist and
pulled her to him she will do it go pray
to your red God like your fire and tell
me what you see
mokoros dark eyes seemed to shine
I see dragons
Wow
[Applause]